hi gang how you doing I'm good buddy
it's so rare I get to hear you use your
actual speaking line oh yeah everyone
says that it's a no II don't even know
what it is anymore I'm figuring it out
I'm a doctor right
no when I the times that I've hung out
with you just in regular life you'll be
like hello there char like Conan it's me
or maybe I'm this guy you spend most of
your life figuring out who am i gay am i
today maybe I'll ask my kids or maybe
I'll ask how Pacino no no you're not
yeah you're you're me no you oh whoa
well they're like you are a genius
yeah you nailed that good you nailed it
I want to start by congratulating you
sincerely Barry instantly became one of
my favorite shows I love that show and
then you win an Emmy I was delighted for
you and I think you deserved it you were
up against that was stiff competition
yeah I mean I thought Ted Danson or
Donald Glover was gonna win and then uh
Anthony Anderson and william h Macy yeah
Larry David and it was it was crazy and
and so how shocked were you when they
said your name I was completely shocked
and I don't remember what I said and
then I went backstage and it's kind of
like people are at you know you're
getting interviewed and stuff and then I
just said can I go to the bathroom and I
went into the stall with Miami and I I
didn't I I sat down on the toilet I
didn't go to the bathroom that would be
a weird story I took a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
any committee Adderley that's yes yeah
Betty White has very similar so I you're
sitting on I put this thought that you
know the seat down I just sat there like
decompressing and the mist all kind of
thinking about what got me to this place
my mind goes to you then open the stall
and you come out holding an Emmy
[Laughter]
you really should hang a little piece of
toilet paper oh this is embarrassing
I'll teach you I mean now you know so
what did you do okay when the ceremony's
over how do you come down from a high
light I what's the first because that's
the kind of thing people want to know
what did you do you won this Emmy you
didn't expect it shows I I don't like
the parties and stuff I'm always a bit
kind of awkward at so I went to in-n-out
burger oh I went to in-n-out burger and
they give you a nice car when you go to
the Emmys and I'm in the back of the car
and this thing rolled them and I'm
paying for my burger and the woman goes
uh didn't you just won an Emmy I go yeah
and she goes can I see it
sure the Emmy right she goes who else is
in there with you I'm like it's just me
and she goes oh baby that's sad
you